Let's take a closer look if we have solved
the problem. First of all, virtual machines are nowadays
a standard offering by any cloud service provider. You
rent any number of virtual machines. And you pay by
the hour, or minute or so. This is called
IaaS, or Infrastructure as a Service. This is, because a
computer and therefore also a virtual machine, can be
considered infrastructure today. So getting back to our original picture.
Problem solved, right? We could use standard virtual
machines from any cloud service provider. And achieve unlimited
scalability by distributing the execution of our application, across
these virtual machines. On a high level, it may
appear so. But let's look at what you
need to do to actually realize this architecture. And
as it turns out, creating this architecture for your
application is a very complicated and resource intensive problem.
Let's look at some of the things you need to think about and take care of.
VM Management. Starting and stopping the virtual machine.
Operating system images. Software
management. Installing, patching and upgrading.
A powerful web server. Installing it and configuring
it for the correct settings. A distributed database
where you can read and write data, from
all of your virtual machines. A distributed file system,
where you can read and write data which is accessible from all your virtual
machines. Application monitoring, with a consolidated view
of any problems occurring in your distributed execution
environment. Availability including data replication, hardware software
resilience, geographic disaster recovery strategies. Back ups, recovery,
automatic fail overs, et cetera. Security set
up and management in your distributed execution environment.
And load balancing. How to spread the load across the
VMs, including application level session management. And all of the
other things that we did not have space to list
here. As you can see, this is an extremely complex problem
to solve in a scalable way. So even though our
solution looked good on a high level. We have now
created an architecture that requires a monumental engineering effort to
realize. At the same time, as you have limited amount of
time and resources. Remember that we started the service
side history, by looking at the server sitting under the
office desk. And sadly enough, for many projects we
have reached a present day. These are the challenges many
projects are facing today, when trying to build scalable
systems. Now, let's do a reality check with a question
for you. Since you have limited time and resources, select
three of these problems you would prioritize over the others.